المواد الإباحية في الوقت الحاضر ، يسهل على
الأطفال الوصول إليها أكثر من أي وقت مضى ، حيث يرون
أجزاء صغيرة من الأشياء تظهر على
أجهزة كمبيوتر الأطفال في المدرسة حتى في المدرسة الابتدائية ،
لذا أصبح من السهل الآن أن تكون جزءًا منتظمًا
من حياة العديد من المراهقين اليومية ،
والأرقام محيرة للعقل.
محير للعقل وفقًا
لتقرير جديد رائد صادر عن Common
Sense وهي شركة إعلامية غير ربحية تركز
على الأطفال والعائلات التي وجدت أن
غالبية المراهقين الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 13 و 17 عامًا قد
شاهدوا المواد الإباحية على الإنترنت إما عن
قصد أو عن طريق الخطأ ، لقد
صدمت جدًا لمعرفة ذلك  73 في المائة
من جميع المراهقين في الولايات المتحدة
يتعرضون للمواد الإباحية على الإنترنت في
كل مكان والأطفال
يصلون إليها في وقت مبكر ، تقرير عن المراهقين
والمواد الإباحية استنادًا إلى
مسح وطني لأكثر من 1300 مراهق ، حيث وجد
أن متوسط ​​عمر الأطفال الذين شاهدوا المواد الإباحية على الإنترنت لأول مرة
كان 12  عامًا ، مع
رؤية حوالي 15 عامًا في سن العاشرة أو أقل ، قال
ثمانية من كل عشرة مراهقين شاهدوا المواد الإباحية
إنهم فعلوا ذلك لتعلم كيفية الحصول على  السابقين
مع قول العديد إنهم شعروا بأن الإباحية عبر الإنترنت
قدمت معلومات مفيدة حول الجنس
ولكن أكثر من نصفهم قد شاهدوا مواد
إباحية تتضمن صورًا للاغتصاب
أو الاختناق أو شخصًا يتألم مما يجعل الإباحية
مصدر قلق متزايد للآباء ، والرابط الواضح
هو أنهم يستخدمون هذا  تحديد
هويتهم الجنسية لتحديد
ما هو مقبول
كيف تصبح إنسانًا
جنسيًا وإذا أصبح هذا ما يعتقدون أنه على
ما يرام ، فأنت تعلم أن هذا هو
ما يتعلمونه من مشاهدته
تقول ميشيل وورستر إنها تراقب مراهقتها
عمليات البحث على الإنترنت ورسائله النصية ،
هناك مشكلة أخرى تتمثل في مقدار
مراقبة الحجر الصحي لـ 44 في
المائة ممن قالوا إنهم
شاهدوا المواد الإباحية عن قصد 71 في المائة أفادوا
بمشاهدتها في الأسبوع الماضي ، وقال ما يقرب من ستة من كل
عشرة إنهم شاهدوا المواد الإباحية مرة واحدة في الأسبوع
أو أكثر.  لا يحدث فقط في
المنزل أو عند الأطفال وقت
فراغ ، تم الإبلاغ عن ثلاثين بالمائة من المراهقين الذين تناولوا المواد الإباحية
تعرضوا لها خلال
اليوم الدراسي.  إنها مدرستها أو أثناء
الذهاب إلى المدرسة عن بُعد في بعض الأحيان حتى
على جهاز أصدرته المدرسة ، يقول
جاك ويست ، مدرس العلوم بالمدرسة الثانوية
في منطقة باي ، إن المدارس لديها
دور تلعبه هنا ، إنها مشكلة متعددة الأوجه
تتطلب نهجًا متعدد الأوجه
لذلك هناك  هناك أولياء الأمور
هناك المعلمون هناك في
المجتمع ونعم في المدارس أعتقد أننا
يجب أن نتعامل مع هذا
ويبدو أن التثقيف الصحي أو التثقيف الجنسي يبدو
مكانًا جيدًا لحدوث ذلك بخلاف
المخاوف بشأن الصور العنيفة أو العدوانية
للجنس ، أبلغ ثلث المراهقين فقط
عن رؤيتهم  الإباحية التي تتضمن
شخصًا يطلب موافقته قبل
الانخراط في نشاط جنسي ، علينا جميعًا
أن نكون جزءًا من الحل هنا
يأمل جيمس ستاير الحس السليم للرئيس التنفيذي في
التقرير شرارة محادثة وطنية على
الآباء أن يكونوا أكثر انخراطًا ويجب على
المدارس الأكثر معرفة أن
تدرك أن هذا  يحدث بالفعل
في المدارس وأنه جزء
من التربية الجنسية
والتربية السلوكية للشباب و q
بصراحة ، يجب أن تكون الصناعة
مسؤولة عن حقيقة أنها
منصات بوابة لكل هذه
المواد الإباحية للشباب Athena Jones
CNN New York